our next speaker is Summit from Colombia
we will talk about Motif counting via
subcraft set
uh thanks Christian
um I'd like to begin by thanking the
organizers for the invitation and also
uh for a wonderful conference so far
um so the talk that I'm going to give
today is joint work with Bashar
um and also shayon Das who's a PhD
student at Columbia
um so so let's uh try and jump right in
uh so the talk will not we have five
parts I'll first explain the question
that we want to study
um and then I'll try and motivate the
answers that we find
um and then I'll use some examples of
graphene symbols uh to illustrate the
results
um depending on the amount of time left
until we have a very high level proof
overview and then conclude
um okay so what is the question that we
want to study so no graph forms here
graphones will make a very brief
appearance in in one slide later on so
so you just have a your secret sequence
of graphs but let's say you have one
large graph
uh which is level whose vertex it is one
two up to vgn whose age set is egn and
that's your that's your parameter of
Interest or that's that sort of you
don't know this graph right this is a
big graph you don't know this you don't
see this
and so on and H is a collected graph of
fixed size you know think of the usual
uh usual candidates uh age is an age or
a triangle or any any motive that you
like stars clicks uh H does not change
with n and I'll assume which is
connected the story should remain the
same if it is not connected
um okay so let NHL you know the number
of copies of hngn by copies I do not
mean induced so the number of injective
homomorphisms
um and so so that's that's what an egn
is and this is our parameter of Interest
we want to understand what this number
is
and so okay so since we do not see this
graph we need to see something and so
what we are going to see is a random sub
graph of this big graph right and so
okay so let's try to explain the
sampling mechanism for this talk
so it's going to be a very simple
sampling mechanism for each uh person in
your network or for each node in your in
your graph decide whether you want to
keep that person in a sample or not so
with probability p n which is again
allowed to change with n
um and ideally I'm thinking of p in
sparse right so P I'm think okay this
most all of this allow
all of this works for PN equal to
prefixed as well but you know
interesting cases will be PN sparse
um so okay so you know you decide
whether that vertex enter your sample or
not and then when you decide which
vertices enter your sample you just take
the induced uh you just take the induced
graph on those vertices so you have a
big graph you choose a bunch of vertices
like this and then just look at the
edges between them so that's your sample
graph that's it so by Chuck by choice
your sample graph is a subgraph of your
big graph
and you know the the name proposed by
people who have looked at this and this
so we did not propose this model uh it's
a subgraph sampling model uh because as
I said your sample graph is a subgraph
of the big graph and the number of
vertices in your sample graph is clearly
random which is a binomial distribution
all very good
and so okay so let's try and come up
with a reasonable estimator and I guess
uh you know this this seems to be the
most natural estimator that one would
come up with so let's let's try and
motivate the estimator so let's see if
you have a particular copy of H let's
say a triangle we 1 in and N minus 2 you
want that copy to be retained in your
sample so you need to pay for you need
to pay for each vertex to enter your
sample so you are going to pay PQ so in
general you are going to pay uh P to the
number of vertices for each copy to
enter your sample
so you know if you denote by n ATN which
is the number of uh number of uh copies
of H in your sample graph GN then this
expectation is just P to the V times the
the number of copies in the big graph
and this gives you your natural
estimator just divide right that's it
um okay so one comment is that this talk
assumes that we know uh P throughout so
you know the sampling probability if you
don't what we can do so what we can do
is if you know the number of vertices in
UB graph you can just estimate p n by
the number of what is a sample by the
number of what is a big graph and the
resulting confidence intervals will only
change by a constant so I'm not going to
talk about that here but you know if you
don't know the number of parties in the
big graph then that's a different story
so that's uh but you know if you don't
do know the number of what is in a big
graph knowing and not knowing PN is not
too much of a difference
okay so so you know uh it was shown in
this paper by uh by Jason klusowski and
Johan that you know this natural
estimator is Minimax rate optimal among
the class of all boundary because where
the bound is of free of n
uh the question that we are going to
take is we are going to we are going to
take the same estimator so so one
comment is that they consider induced
copies and here we are going to not
consider endoscopics of course you know
you can write one in terms of the other
as a
inclusion exclusion formula but uh so
the question that we want to study for
this talk is is uh is sort of the more
classical statistical questions of
consistency and asymptotic distribution
so that's the question that we want to
study so therefore in in our minds we
have a sequence of graph G and and PN
and as such there is no assumption as
how you get GL you could get it from a
graph one model you could not that's
fine so of course we need some
assumptions okay you will see you will
see the assumptions coming in but you
know as such there is no your gns are
not random
yes are you assuming that your graphs
are dense though no
GN is not dense
so Gene is just a sequence of graphs but
then it could very well be that n is
just zero yeah that's possible we'll of
course in that case estimation would not
be possible
I'm sorry so so which so if if this is
so in our next slide we'll rule out the
case that that is zero so so this
estimator is always defined doesn't mean
that you'll do well
characterize precisely when it will do
well right so to but to Define this
estimator we can always do it right so I
have a related question so in in the
result of Wu and klusovsky
um
I'm slightly astonished that this works
in the boundary decrease setting because
again this number could actually
go easily to zero or something I mean
right because you may not say it may
contain many copies of a certain graph
which you just don't see by this random
sampling right so the point is that if
if it if it is zero then no estimator
will do better right so if this this
estimator is Minimax at optimal meaning
in the settings where so it's min max
operating under that sampling scheme
under the sampling scheme because you
might have a different sampling scheme
which sort of has same complexity which
gives you the correct count
I fully agree with you so this is so you
fix the sampling scheme so throughout
the talk we'll use this what examples so
when they say min max Optimum that means
for fixed PN and so
for fixed pm
if you look at if it is if your GN is
among this estimator is Minimax adopting
I see so what they're saying is if I
sort of have the sampling scheme I get
as input to induce little GMS right any
estimator which uses that as an input
yes just counting is min max exactly
optimal and makes a lot of sense have a
look at induced graphs because if you if
you are since this allows bar setting
induced graphs behave slightly better in
this bar settings and sub graphs right
and and and sort of the point is uh so
so so so one one thing which I wanted to
sort of uh wanted to sort of point out
in the middle of your question is it is
perfectly possible and that there is a
different sampling screen which does
much better if you want to count let's
say motives right and and so for example
if your graphs have if your big graph G
as varying Agency for example if you
know that there is a you know Hub here
somewhere then ideally I would use more
sampling power there and if there is a
you know less edges somewhere ideally I
will use less sampling part there but
this means that I know something more
about the big graph GL which is not sort
of part of our modeling assumption
so right now we are fully agnostic about
the GL big graph GN and and this is the
sampling scheme yeah yes there would
still be many possible asset sampling
scheme lives choose K random points and
true supports of radius K around them
you're like you're right and and I agree
that in if you should make the snap pics
different other estimators could be more
natural that's perfectly possible
other questions about the model
understanding scheme
right okay uh so so what we want to
understand is where is this consistent
if you have a sequence of graph G and p
n and when it is asymptote normal okay
we don't do that you know what is
asymptote distribution of this
so I put the word consistency in quotes
because of course uh we need to make
some sense of it because typically you
know in the in the at least in the in
when you say something is consistent in
statistics we have a sequence of
estimators trying to estimate a real
number uh the difference you know needs
to go to zero however as you might kiss
so as you might guess
um you know the type of examples that we
look at the number of copies of H and GN
will be large
and so of course you don't want the
different close to zero because that
means you have to be exactly equal which
is a bit too much so we demand the most
national thing you know we demand ratio
consistency right so and and here we
sort of throughout uh you know through
you know we will assume that the number
of copies of 18g n is greater than equal
to one otherwise I don't even know how
to make sense of this so throughout
we'll assume that there is at least one
copy of hngn and and just to give you an
Insight this will never be consistent if
this doesn't go to Infinity so you can
only you know this will come this will
come later but at this point at this
point this will be an assumption
throughout
so this is what consistency will mean
for us the ratio going to one
yes
I'm a little bit confused
maybe it's very natural to think of this
in the limit but I have no idea how this
changes with end so your your graph is
you said you're agnostic on the big
graph fine but and you're keeping the
sampling scheme but you're adding pu for
every new vertex U and no no BN is no no
so so when you when you give me the
graph at the nth level so think of n so
for us for you know suppose N is a
hundred and suppose you know suppose you
observe the graph 100 vertices and
suppose you decide your sampling
probability p n is uh you know 0.03
that's it so for fixed n for all the
edges I use the same p and then when for
n plus one for n plus one I use p n plus
one A different p
so but basically you so so think of the
think of the statistical question where
you you are usually given X One X to
extend from some distribution you are
not given the whole sequence right so
this is so you will only be given GNP
and for some n but all I'm saying is
that there is an underlying GNP and
which you could have been given so
there's an underlying x 1 x 2 x n or you
could have been given x 1 x to X N Plus
1.
I think it's still a little bit subtle
but okay so so I can go with this so I
think I think one point is I think what
you're trying to ask is how does GN plus
one how is n plus one operate from GL
right the answer is no restrictions you
can build it in any way you want
so no consistency in a different sense
no consistency of law if you're thinking
of uh so so if you have gnij that is
present GN plus one may or may not so
it's perfectly okay to build India
consistent way nothing will change
that's the point this will not impact
anything that I'm doing
um okay uh
so let's see so let's see an example I
think this will uh this this may answer
some questions so suppose GN is a line
graph on N word it says with n minus one
ages you have a big line so this is what
I mean Gene changing within right so
this is a GN
and so suppose H is a path of length two
three vertices to edges so you want to
count the number of copies of H and g n
so essentially the number is n minus two
right one two three two three four three
four five and so on just sort of have a
moving window and you get this number n
minus 2 which is basically n for all
practical purposes
and so okay uh you know now so we have
some sample probability p n and this is
where this is the p n part
and so what will be your GL well if you
choose just one vertex and don't choose
your neighbors you'll be an isolated
vertex if you choose to consecutive an
edge if you choose three consecutive
path of length two larger length three
and so on so basically your sample graph
will be a disjoint Union of passive
varying lens depending on which ones are
possible and which ones are not so that
will be your sample graph
and so how many parts of them two will
you see
if you take the expectation well you get
npq mini Paths of length two
uh because you want to select all the
three vertices due to PPQ for that now
of course you can do this consideration
only when this goes to Infinity but this
is the expected number and if it goes to
Infinity this is the right number of
Paths of length 2 that you will see
now if you have H tilde which is a path
of length 3 then you are going to see NP
to the four many copies of that so you
know there's a reason for including HP H
tilde even though I want I want to count
h
so okay so suppose p n is such that the
first number goes to infinity and the
second number goes to zero so
essentially you are saying that uh
you know there are no Paths of length
three and there are lots of parts of
length 2 and of course there are Paths
of length one and they're isolated party
systems so they are also those so your
sample graph is a disjoint Union of
Paths of length 0 1 and 2 with high
probability not two sample graph so
you're a big graph use a sample graph
and so okay so your estimator is this
and so with high probability this will
be npq over P Cube and it if this goes
to Infinity
and this will be in which is sort of
close so in this setting it is actually
consistent so this is what I mean by so
your p n changing with n so I hope this
answers some of the some of the
questions uh that we uh
right so this is and as such I did not
put any assumptions with p n other than
this is the this is sort of the
assumption that I put here and I'll try
to you know will be precise about
exactly what we need for consistency but
this is just a dummy example yes
why do you need the N times p n to the
power 4 to go to zero but just to give
you a structure of you know just to just
to be able to write this line
otherwise you'll also have Regent in a
possible entries
this is just to just to give you a nice
so you know just to give you a
description that's it okay yeah the
expected value is going to be more ah
yeah I'm not claiming that exactly I'm
not claiming that I need this for
consistency okay this is just an example
to say how the sample graph looks like
and then say that in this case your
estimator is consistent
um okay so you know the point is that
your sample graph GN okay depends on
your perspective but doesn't look like
your big graph but uh you know it's
still consistent with very small P right
you don't need P to be fixed here you P
can go to zero at reasonable radius
uh okay so the normal you know the
asymptotic distribution part is more
standard but let me still just say what
we what we you know what is the question
we want to study so this is our
estimator you Center and scale it the
usual way this same as starting the
number of copies of H in your sample
graph centered in scale
um
okay
um
as one might guess maybe it's gaussian
uh however as it turns out and this I
will I'll sort of go brief you over in
the example uh in the later part of the
top I hope I have some time for that uh
this does not hold here in the sense
that it's possible for your estimator to
be consistent but this fluctuations to
be not non-trivial and non-notional the
exam in the example it will be a sent
that poisson and in particular the class
of limits could be a gaussian and a
poisson and a mixture of this and and we
don't know the class of all
possibilities and that's uh but okay so
so you know so the modified question
that we propose for the talk which we
will answer is that can we say exactly
when it conversion normal zero one so
ideally not a sufficient condition but
you know if and only if uh you know when
can we when can we estimate the normal
distribution to uh you know find out
confidence intervals for this quantity
so these are the questions that we want
to study in this talk
so that's uh that's the setup of the
talk uh so now let's uh try and answer
them
explain why we anticipate answers that
we do
so let's ask the consistency question
right there was this dummy example where
things were Pistons are nice and and all
the moment calculations walk through
so in general it's not always consistent
and you know it's not hard to think of
uh what could go wrong
you take GN to be an N star so you know
here the number of vertices actually in
plus one but that doesn't matter you
could take any drawing sequence and
things are fine
it is an edge and your sampling through
VPN is a half and you do you can also
give examples with P equal to zero
so okay so there's a hand-drawn picture
your k n herein is five and there are
two possibilities essentially right
either you get to choose the central
Vertex or you don't now if you don't
choose your central vertex what you are
going to see is just a bunch of isolated
vertices here right just a bunch of
leaves here and in this case here is
your your number of edges in the sample
graph will be exactly Z that's it
on the other hand if you happen to
choose your central vertex which happens
with probability half then the now then
you essentially what you see is a star
graph right I mean what you see is a
smaller star graph and and then the
number of edges is a binomial in half
right I mean the number of leaves that
you choose so that's these are the two
possibilities
so let's uh try and write them down so
with probability half uh you see a bunch
of isolated vertices
um so in this case your estimator is
exactly zero there's nothing there's
nothing going on
uh with already half you choose the
central vertex then your sample graph is
a star graph
but with binomial many vertices in this
case we estimated is four times x n you
get the 4 because of the half square
right you have half Square scaling so
that gives you the four
so your estimator n hat is zero it will
be half and four times x n with 40 half
if you take if you take limits you will
get 0 over half and two is equal to half
so in this example for this sequence of
graphs
this nice estimator is not consistent
but it's yes
well I mean the the the the brief answer
could also be playing Devil's Advocate
that you should not do sampling for a
star right sub sampling that that would
be the answer yes you're right and and
the answer is it's it's not sufficiently
well connected and you can destroy the
entire spots one Vortex some people are
not supposed to be more much more
popular than others precisely exactly
it's not robusting that's it exactly
it's not robust incident and that is
what we will make precise yes you're
right
because in this setting to make it work
you sort of have to know that there is
this popular guy and other I don't know
of national sampling schemes which will
work here but okay that's I mean of
course naturally has been in codes here
um okay so as rainbow pointed out you
know big and big is compared to the
others big is not just within yourself
because compared to relative to the
graph big degree vertices are not good
for you
so so okay so presence of big degree
vertices is going to in your sample is
going to boost up your estimate too much
absence will you know sort of reduce it
to too low and
it's essentially what you want is is to
have the number of big degree
contributions the contribution of the I
mean I do we don't want to remove the
big degrees entirely but we want to
ensure that the big degree contribution
is low and the precise characterization
uh for the age case we will sort of
answer the general more General cases
theorem but let's first start with the H
case
if you sum over the degrees without
which are large and large is exactly
this threshold and you divide by the
total number of edges that has to go to
zero for every Epsilon frame
so this is the first
question
is this related to some form of uniform
integrability
um
maybe maybe that's a good so so
essentially essentially what we do is we
truncate the graph and we sort of do a
second moment I'm going to the truncated
graph so but you're saying that it's
exactly equal to zero not that
advantages or very oh there's a limit
there's a limit sorry sorry that's the
type there's a limit okay ah there's a
limit okay my bad there is a limit
that's closer no no that's that's a big
difference so I couldn't I cannot write
there but there's a limit right yes so
when you're estimating that I think you
did the mic sorry
for the estimation of just the ages if
we have sampled the ages instead of the
viruses then you always get the
consistent estimation right
for very spot I mean okay that's a
question that we are trying to study now
I am not sure about the answer so let's
talk about that offline that's that's
work in progress
um
yes there's a question
for this condition you don't know
anything about the graph GMA
right then how do you know
so so I mean it's it's a general thing
right you can only so the conditions for
consistency usually depends on the
unknown parameters that's that's in
general you know ubiquitous through
statistics so problem you started with
you don't know anything about right
right and so so I'll give you sufficient
conditions later which you can check
again by plugging in estimates but these
are Stairway to inference right I mean
suppose you want to estimate the mean in
a normal family the the bounds are given
by the variance you now we need to
estimate the variance and now the the
bound to the variance will have some
other parameters involved right is the
usual stairway of inference problems you
can never stop this at some stage you
decide okay that's that so but you can
continue this so I'll tell you how to
check this condition
right but again checking this condition
will assume something more so it's not
this will not be blanket
okay and also the expected number of
copies of edges have to go to Infinity
this is sort of the equivalent of saying
the sample size goes to Infinity so this
sort of says that you know if this is
too small like five or six this is not
going to work
right so you need you need enough number
of edges in the big graph and enough
being Quantified by this P Square
and this is not a sufficient criteria
this is an exact criter it is an if and
only so if this doesn't hold your
stimulator will fail that's it period
right so that's what's going on for ages
so let's now let's now State the first
result which is uh our first main result
is what's going on for HS General H's
the same story holds I mean you want to
estimate the score in number of copies
of H and g n what we need to control are
groups of vertices which contributes too
many copies of H right that's what's
going to mess up your estimator so let's
define the analog of degrees in this
context
suppose you have a set a of what is in
vgn whose size is less than V of H then
the th of a denote the number of copies
of H passing through it right so let's
just
what does that mean uh passing through
means the number of indicative such that
you know so so for the single case let
me write it down
does it mean the vertex set has non-zero
intersection or does it mean it's
contained uh not content so let's see so
so let's see suppose H is a triangle
then
pH of uh one comma 3 is the sum over I A
1 I a three I
so it's a number of uh so so one and
three are given to you is the number of
triangles passing through
it's a number of angles like this
so
number of
it is a number of age whose vertex set
contains a right
and okay so the same story holds so now
there is a limit so that's good uh your
estimator is is consistent if and only
for every Epsilon this sum you not have
to sum over all sides of phase starting
from one all the way up to VH then this
th indicator this truncation point this
is small compared to the total number of
uh total number of copies of H into n
uh so so so the next slide parses this
for the age condition and convinces you
this is exactly what we obtained for the
age case but any yes
what is passing through a you only need
notes uh in so here you said edge one
and three present in the Triangle or
right so so a is a subset of a is a
subset of nodes and then th of it you
don't want the induced graph of a to be
present no no just the notes right
foreign
okay so let's try and explain why this
gives you exactly what we got in the age
case now the way to get the H case is to
consider sizes of a which is one and two
separation that's it that will give you
the two conditions right so because for
the h case VH is two
and so okay uh
continuity is one or two and therefore
if you get if you get uh you know if you
look at size of a of degree if you look
at PSI s it's a of size 1 then th of a
is exactly the degree so you get back
this condition again with a limit which
is missing so I apologize for that
uh on the other hand if you look at
sizes a or a is of size 2 Then basically
you get the indicator so you're summing
over indicate age indicator age bigger
than this cutoff this has to uh you know
the limit has to go to zero now this
doesn't exactly look like it but but a
moment's thought shows that this is
exactly same as this why if this is
going to Infinity then for every Epsilon
fixed this will be this will go to
Infinity so this will never happen and
this is zero on the other hand if this
is bounded then for Epsilon small enough
this would be one so this whole thing
will be two so you know this criteria is
just more convenient written like this
but injured in general that's what it is
right
so okay
um
let's try to answer the yes
[Music]
and to Infinity yes yes
you need that that that's all that
always the follows from taking a which
is the maximum size
right the way to get that would be
taking a to be the VH exactly
so okay so so asymptotic distributions
uh so we Center and scale we want to
know the limit on this
and as I try to indicate uh you know
this may not have a gaussian limit even
though your stimulator is consistent
let's try to go over briefly over
example this example is sort of of
course we needed some time to come up
with example so let's try to explain
what this example is doing you have uh
login many in stars and log in many
clicks and the size of the clicks is a
to the 7 over 12. of course these were
carefully chosen
um
and so this is your big graph and you
see you know Parts with varying agency
of course that's allowed and okay so you
choose your what he says you choose your
samples so samples can come from here
and so here the red okay the color is
okay I guess visible the red ones are
the central vertices of the of the stars
that you choose the green ones are the
leaves that you choose and Y represents
the number that you choose from here so
Y is a binomial X is a Bernoulli here
depending on just indicating whether you
choose that one or not and Z is
represent the number of uh the number of
things that we choose per click so these
also a binomial
so the so so this is so this is a this
is a big graph and a particular relation
of two of choice of samples is indicated
by the colors and so what is the number
of pages so I'm Distributing number of
edges just to be clear so the number of
edges is you have to choose this one
that accounts for the X I then you
multiply by how many of the Y I's you
choose 6 i y i Plus Part three you get Z
I choose two so where x i is a Bernoulli
y i is a binomial in p z i is a binomial
into the 7 over 12. so you can write
very explicitly uh the number of
you know the number of edges that come
in you sample so it's it's not you know
I mean this is a very nice okay I mean
random variable you can analyze it to
death
um okay so and as I indicated in the
last slide you have login mini stars and
login mini clicks
and how many vertices do you have so
login times part star you have n many
vertices and part three you have into
the seven many what is vertices so this
one dominates n log in many vertices and
uh per pile we have this Factor log n
part star you have n many edges but you
have you know this becomes quadratic now
and this one dominates for the age one
so it will be seven over six log in many
edges so for the vertex one the star
Parts terminate for the age for the h
part uh for the h part uh The Click spot
dominate
that's okay so as I as I wrote in the
last slide this is the exact
representation for the number of
monochromatic ages
so x i is a Bernoulli y i is a binomial
GI is that a defined binary so this is
this is just what I what I had in the
last slide just written more cleanly
and so let's try and check the
consistency I'll gloss over the limit
distribution part but that's in our
paper so we choose P to be 1 over log
and so this is the exact condition again
with the limit there were these other
conditions with that one also that's
easier to check
um
so what is the number of edges from the
computation that we did this is n27 over
6 times long and P is one over log which
cancels this so you get into the seven
over six right so number of edges times
P this is your threshold actually is a
to the 7 over 6 yes 1 over
1 over the number of edges should be one
over p n times the number of edges right
uh one over the number of pages this
this should be this should always be the
number of edges here the threshold has P
this one does not have p here
uh only the threshold has
um okay so the threshold that you need
to compare here is interview seven over
six but that's great because you know
this is your truncation point but you
don't need to trunk it at all uh because
you know the star graph at maximum
degree n and the clicks at maximum
degree n27 over 12 which is much less
than n so this is zero for all you know
for every fix we don't fix for all in
large enough this quantity is exactly
zero and therefore it's consistent you
know you cannot check this by a direct
second moment argument but you know it
shows that electronication will work and
that's that's actually what our theorem
does as well
and then you know so consistency holds
uh the limit is a center poisson let me
let me gloss over that fat because it
sort of involves more computation with
that formula but it's it's not too bad
at all
um okay
that's that's the loop so so in general
the question
so please
what was the person uh limit of uh limit
of the number
so so you take the number of edges in
your sample graph
subtract is expectation divided by
square root of the variance so you do
that you do the thing which is supposed
to take you to normal and it ends up in
a synthetic poisson center part is fine
because you think that mean zeros per
limit should have mean zero that part is
fine
but the poisson part is surprised
foreign
you still end up getting something
that's integer value or almost integer
value which seems surprising maybe I'm
just missing something uh so maybe we
can go over the computations sure
um okay
uh
so so there are two ways and where does
disease go
where do the disease because these so
well concentrated that they vanish in
the distribution so the Z's I think the
fluctuations of z's are of smaller order
so Z contributes more to the mean but
less to the values
the fluctuations of Z's so right so
that's that I think is the answer to
Shankar's question I was trying to
remember as answering the fluctuations
of the z's are of lesser order so
essentially it's just the first part
which contribution to the answer and
that's why you get uh an integer value
random variable
so these only contribute exactly so the
Z's make sure that you're consistent
exactly but they don't contribute to the
fluctuations exactly that's how the PS
were chosen to make our life easy
so okay so
what could we do well uh so one question
which I still find interesting which I
which we don't know I think currently
how to do is character as a class of all
possible limits when you estimate is
consistent
uh okay so that's that the other one is
can we say when is this exactly gaussian
and that's something we should try and
answer in the next two results
and how much time do you have left
five minutes five minutes so okay
I see okay uh so okay let me try uh let
me go over the result and then I'll go
over some examples as well if okay so if
p is less than 1 over 20 p l so it's a
sequence upper bounded by this number
then the washer time distance between
the center and available normal 0 1 is
bounded by a constant times the fourth
moment minus three
so that's uh that's uh the second main
result and you know as you can guess
this is an application and size method
of dependency graphs you cannot directly
use the theorem yourself have to go into
the you know bounds and tweak it a bit
but that's that's fine
uh and this sort of tells you that
whenever the fourth moment goes to three
if p is less than one over 20 your
random will go to normal zero one so
that's uh that's that so of course in
that example the photo doesn't go to G
but that's that's that's okay so an
example of a fourth moment phenomena and
of course there are lots of examples of
this as far as we know the first example
was discovered in this paper by Nola ten
picati but by now you know there's a lot
of if for more examples uh you know you
can see Ivan root this web page where
dedicated to just connecting examples of
photo
so there's many examples where you know
we have linear you know multi-linear
form of random variables and and such a
fourth moment uh thing happens
so let me just go over some quick
comments uh you do need some so you know
the upper bound PLS and 1 over 20 is not
an artifact you do need some bound on P
for this photo point to hold we have
another counter example again built of
starts and clicks of different sizes
where PN is p which is fixed which is
larger than one about 20 foot one goes
to three the limit is not gout
uh if I remember correctly there is no
limit
okay uh also so it's a counter example
for arbitrary p and small so what if p
is
PN is sort of one over 18.
so we have for example so the count
example is very sensitive there's a
polynomial which we want to vanish so
the counter example that works for the
specific P will not work for even if you
change P plus minus Epsilon and what we
think is that it will only break down
accountability mini piece
but as a countable many pieces breaks
down to the I have an accumulation point
at 1 over 20. we don't know that we do
so we have one Capital fixed p and we
know that P for p small enough things
are fine
I see but you don't know what the
critical p is right right that we do not
know that's that's yeah
um
for the questions at the end sorry
um okay also the Fortnight condition is
only sufficient in particular you know
uh we have examples where this goes to
normal and also p goes to zero so the 14
doesn't go to three so that's also
possible and so I promised you an if and
only criteria let me just state that
quickly and then and I'll stop so
the exactly okay I guess it's a bit
notationally messy but let's let's
quickly go over that
um
or maybe maybe let's keep this and just
State the result
so we have a truncated version of the
count so this let me not explain what
the translated version of account is
because it will take more than five
minutes but we have a truncated version
of the count not the actual count if the
truncated version of the count the
second moment goes to one and the Fourth
Movement goes to three this is if and
only if your original lineup will goes
to a normal so there is a
characterization of exact normality that
is in terms of a truncated Fourth
Movement phenomenon where the
translation is essentially you count the
number of all good copies of your sample
good means that a copy of a triangle is
good if all of its subsets are good
meaning that there are not too many
triangles passing through this pair not
two rectangles passing through this pair
not too many angles causing through this
pair they are not to which angles
passing through this vertex this vertex
in this vertex and so on so there's an
exact so the exact condition of good is
is is is here it's a different cutoff
than the last one but I'm happy to talk
about that uh
is there questions
um but this is the exact if and only
result and I guess I'm almost out of a
question on your serum can you yes put
to see on
um does the CM says if there exists an M
or what does it because M seems yes so
theorem says that the dogs
this time I did not forget to put the
limit so there is a limit Over N so the
double limit second moment has to go to
one and the fourth moment so this means
that Rim Supreme soup has to be one and
limits right
in the sense of dominance
um okay so let me quickly I guess
this sort of okay this let me just go
over some examples rather than
explaining the simulation
so for dense crafts which is the main
focus of this uh this Workshop uh the
picture is actually very easy suppose
Junior sequence of things graphs
converging cosmetic to a graph on W
which is density positive essentially
all that we care about is this is in
square many edges and n2b H many copies
of VH that's all we care about we don't
actually care that it has a limit
uh then the result is actually very
simple I mean you have to manipulate our
sufficient conditions a bit to get this
but you know the exact result is NP goes
to Infinity so if NP is bounded your
estimator is neither consistent
non-normal on the other hand if NP goes
to Infinity the estimator is both
consistent and normal so the exact
is an exact characterization of
normality here
uh we give yes
oh okay
for the consistency PN is just not going
to one p n is less than 1 minus Kappa
but for the normality
well
um
what happened in this examples we
learned in the last few days where you
have different scalings depending on
what the sub process and craftfulness so
why is that not an issue here
so there is a slight difference between
that setup and our setup right in that
setup there's an underlying W which
gives see the big graph which you fully
observe and here our starting point so
essentially the centering is different
here our starting point is the big graph
and then we fought the sample a small
graph right and so the setting is a bit
different
so so I don't think in in Basha setting
or in additional setting you never get a
percentage if I understand correctly
you'll never get a center question
whereas in our case you can so it's a
bit different
um I guess my time is up but yeah
okay thank you
okay and